-So your book,
"Outside the Wire,"
references when you were
serving in Afghanistan
and you would leave the base
to go talk to people.
You were also, after you
returned from Afghanistan,
27 years old when you were
elected to state office.
-Yeah.
-What was it like being
that young in the statehouse?
-Well, so this is the oldest
I´ve ever been.
[ Laughter ]
So we´ll start there.
I got to Jefferson City, and
people would always ask me --
I think they meant,
"Who do you intern for?"
and they would say,
"Who do you work for?"
and I would say,
"35,000 Kansas Citians."
And, you know, from there,
every office I´ve ever run for,
I´ve kind of been the young guy
running for it.
So I guess, what was it like?
I helped a lot of people
with their smartphones and...
[ Laughter ]
I explained Twitter.
-That´s nice.
Do you look back and say,
"That was a terrible thing
to do to old people?
-Explain Twitter?
I didn´t explain it to this guy.
[ Laughter ]
-That´s not on you.
-That´s not me.
-So I also want to ask --
You ran as a progressive.
And there seems to be
this same conversation
that we had in the 2016 election
about the Democratic party,
and the progressive wing
and the moderate wing.
And you have somebody like
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
where moderate Democrats
are saying
there´s a very scary thing.
We have to be careful
about the progressive Democrats
taking over the party.
Where do you stand on that,
as a progressive yourself?
-So I actually think this
is a totally false choice.
You know, what I write about
in "Outside the Wire" is that,
it´s really about going out
and trying to convince people
of things,
and it has been to be
what you genuinely believe.
Voters will forgive you
for believing something
they don´t believe as long as
they know you really believe it
and you believe it
´cause you care about them.
When I was running
for the Senate in ´16,
I would be in Kansas City,
talking about equal pay,
like a Planned Parenthood event.
And then I´d go to a rural area
a couple hours later
and be a room full
of middle-class men,
and I would -- I would still
talk about equal pay.
But I would point out to them,
like, if their wife
is making less money than a man
doing the same job,
they both have less money
to send their kid to college.
So you win arguments
by making arguments.
You don´t win arguments by
trying to make people believe
that you actually believe
the same thing.
Like, you can´t win an argument
with your roommate that way,
let alone the electorate.
-Right.
You also believe a false choice
that seems to be
what Democrats
are talking about right now is,
do you choose
to try to flip Trump voters
to the Democratic Party,
especially ones
that were Democrats
before he came on the scene,
or do you just ignore them
and try to get voters
who haven´t voted before?
Do you also believe
that´s a false choice?
-Well, yeah, because, again, you
win arguments by making them.
So, like,
I learned this really early.
I tell a story in the book
about how
one of the very first doors
I ever knocked on
when I was running
for the state legislature,
this fella came out,
we talked for a second.
It was really clear,
we did not agree on this issue.
And I kind of
panicked a little inside,
and I started to do what
I´d seen politicians on TV do.
So I start trying to spin him,
make him think
we believe the same thing,
and it wasn´t working,
and, finally, I just was like,
"I got to get out of here."
So I said, you know, "Thanks.
That´s what I believe.
I guess we disagree."
And I go to walk off,
and he´s like, "That´s fair.
I´ll vote for you.
You can put a sign in my yard."
[ Laughter ]
And so, like,
what I learned from that is,
the reason
it´s a false choice is, like,
the people
who already agree with you,
they can see that you go out
and make your argument
to people who may not,
and they appreciate that,
and they get excited.
They want to go
knock on doors for you.
And these people over here who
don´t currently agree with you,
like, if you make your argument,
you might convince some of them.
And if you just try and pretend
you believe
the same thing as them,
they´re gonna be like,
"I don´t buy it."
So, like, now, I´m running
for mayor of Kansas City,
and just like
any other campaign I´ve had,
I´m out there talking to folks
about what´s going on
on their street.
I´m not pretending we live
on the same street, you know?
I´m like, "Hey,
I´m seeing a lady in a few days
who has a possum problem."
Like, I´m gonna go walk around,
we´re gonna look at that.
It´s important.
-You´re gonna look
at the possum problem?
-Absolutely.
We got to try and fix it.
Government is about trying
to solve people´s problems.
-I mean, I thought politicians
had the most boring lives.
That sounds kick-ass!
-Come with me!
-I´m down.
I´ll bring my possum gloves.
-If you have some,
I´d like to borrow them.
[ Laughter ]
No, but, like,
you know, we joke about it,
but that´s what the best
argument for progressive values
is progress that people can see,
you know?
And so, in my town,
we´ve had awesome progress,
and I want to make sure
everybody in town
can see it and feel it.
That´s why I decided to run.
-You -- You´ve always criticized
the idea of money in politics,
getting it out of politics,
and when you were running --
when you were raising money,
your opponent started doing this
and bringing this
to your rallies, your events.
This was called
the Kander Pander.
-Yeah.
-And it was a guy
in a panda suit.
-Which is what
I like to call a stretch.
[ Laughter ]
So was the Kander Pander
something that you were aware of
and did you have
to plan around it?
-Yeah,
I thought it was hilarious.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I tell a story in the book
how we had to have, like,
routes of ingress and egress
to go around it.
You know,
which is a military term.
that, clearly,
no one here knows.
[ Laughter ]
But now you do.
And so what was amazing to me
was there was a dude who --
That was his job.
-Yeah.
-And it was hot sometimes.
And what I do respect about it
was that, one time,
a group of, like, I think,
kindergartners came,
and all they knew -- they
didn´t know it was politics.
They just thought,
"There´s a panda."
-Yeah.
-And, like, it was hot,
but he stayed and took pictures
with all of them.
-That´s really nice.
-Yeah.
-The thing that seems
really cruel to me is,
they make him wear a panda suit,
and then they just, like,
go to Kinkos and print out
Kander Pander.
-Yeah, that´s a good point.
They got to put
some production value in there.
-Yeah, he could´ve been like,
"Can´t I have one
that goes around my neck so I
don´t have to hold it all day?"
-The point of all it, though,
is how insane
the system is, right?
I mean, the fact that, like,
I had to go all over the country
raising money
for a senate race in Missouri,
because you have
to raise so much money.
At one point --
Like, you would --
It was like speed dating.
You would sit in these meetings,
and I had this fear.
It wasn´t even fear,
it was a reality.
Halfway through, sometimes,
I would forget the name
of the person,
but they didn´t know.
And I was afraid
that they were gonna be like,
"What´s my name?"
[ Laughter ]
And, one day,
this dude says to me --
This very nice man
who helped the campaign.
He says to me, he says,
"Do you know John Smith?"
And I´m in my head, like,
"I really thought
this was John Smith."
And I´m like,
"Oh, my God, it´s happening!"
And so I didn´t know what to do,
so I just bit the bullet,
and I´m like,
"Aren´t you John Smith?"
and he just acted like that´s
the dumbest thing he ever heard.
He´s like, "I´m talking about
the other John Smith."
[ Laughter ]
And I´m like so relieved
when he said that.
I start just laughing like the
joker, just like cracking up.
Anyway, I walked out of there
with a campaign check
and an introduction
to the other John Smith.
-There you go.
That works out perfectly.
-Worked out great.
Yeah.
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
Best of luck with everything.